[Music]
here's how it happens you're drifting
off to sleep or maybe you wake up in the
middle of the night you feel a presence
in the room you see something out of the
corner of your eye you try to look but
you can't move you try to call out but
you're unable to make a sound there's an
invisible weight on your chest even
breathing is difficult you strain to
look and then you see it the shadow of a
person you can't detect any features but
every Instinct you have tells you this
entity is not friendly you hear a light
hum and maybe a rush of air and the dark
entity vanishes you've just encountered
a shadow person now this one was pretty
benign but there are some shadow people
sightings that are more intense more
real these encounters can be traumatic
and in some cases violent I should know
because it happened to me
foreign
culture has their own paranormal Legends
Asian cultures European American and so
on some myths exist in cultural subsets
like religions and individual countries
even small towns and neighborhoods have
their own Legends people raised in
Michigan might not know what a
chupacabra is but they've heard of the
dog man Americans might laugh at the
story of Krampus the evil version of
Santa Claus who is half goat half demon
and punishes children but mention him to
kids in Germany or Austria and they
won't find it funny visitors to
Ronkonkoma New York enjoy swimming in
the Clear Lake in the middle of town but
locals don't go in the water out of fear
of tuscawanta the Algonquin princess who
drowns one young man every year in
search of true love or the crib kit the
what no the crab cat all goldfish are
afraid of him he's half crib half cat
who works in a sushi body underworld
they have sushi in the Underworld before
the crib kid appears you hear him
sharpening his blade and the room will
smell like sake it's crab cat catches
you he meows Omakase then he cuts off
one of your fins and you spend all of
eternity swimming in circles circles oh
because he cuts off one thing
Fear The Crab cat whether a chupacabra
evil Santa Claus or a crab cat these
stories couldn't be any more different
but one Legend is universal Shadow
People shadow people are seen in every
culture on Earth and Shadow People
encounters have been happening for
thousands of years and of all the
thousands or maybe millions of Shadow
People encounters over the years the
descriptions are eerily similar most
often they appear as nothing more than
Silhouettes they lack defining
characteristics you can feel that there
are facial features there but you can't
see them the majority of Shadow people's
sightings happen when you're in bed at
night though they have been seen outside
especially in dark wooded areas but a
few shadow people have been seen in
broad daylight it's not uncommon to hear
a humming or a buzzing or a whooshing
sound when a shadow person is present
and some people hear electricity and
some people hear the shadow person
Whispering or even screaming in their
ear in most cases the shadow people will
disappear when you see them they'll zip
into a corner fly through a wall or just
fade away but in some rare cases shadow
people don't disappear they become more
clear and detailed and in very rare
cases shadow people can be violent
hey Jane hecklefish the first attached
image was from the West Virginia
Penitentiary in Moundsville West
Virginia it's a really tricky place that
my paranormal team and myself have
investigated many times this was
captured in the cafeteria by our night
vision camera we investigate in complete
darkness and heard movement behind us
the camera captured this figure and it's
known to haunt this location the second
attached image was caught by Oakmont
paranormal in a joint investigation of
the Andrew Carnegie Library and Music
Hall in Pittsburgh it looks to have
glowy eyes the lady sitting in front of
the figure called our attention to the
movement around her and said that she
was feeling sick
we're gonna do a complete walk through
hope you guys say something or do
something good online it's God no oh
[Music]
the Choctaw have been in America for
almost 4 000 years they were among the
Five Civilized Tribes as described by
Europeans meaning the Choctaw had an
organized and advanced Society they had
a high literacy rate they had
centralized governments with written
constitutions they had a merchant class
and would trade with other tribes as
well as with Europeans the Choctaw would
accept white and black people into their
tribes through marriage and despite all
these modern sensibilities the Choctaw
had a rich mythology they have a story
about the nalusa Cheeto this is a shadow
being who appears when someone allows
evil thoughts to enter their mind the
new lucachito appears while they're
sleeping and devours their soul these
entities are so terrifying to the
Choctaw that to this day many people
will not say the name the Choctaw also
have an elusivelya which literally
translates to long black being this is a
shadow person who lives in the woods and
appears at dusk to torment hunters and
children who stray too far from Camp
cultures from all over the world have
similar Legends medieval Europeans fear
the incubus who assaults women while
they sleep the succubus assaults men the
word nightmare comes from ancient
Germanic or Norse a mayor or Mara is a
demon that sits on your chest and tries
to strangle you while you sleep this
creature is known as kikimura to
Russians Czechs and poles even the
Sumerians 5 000 years ago told stories
of the Aloo the aloe roams the night
searching for victims who are asleep the
Aloo can paralyze you possess you and
put you in a coma in Arabian and Islamic
mythology and theology Jinn are
supernatural creatures created from
smokeless and scorching fire many
Muslims believe the Jinn are real an
individual member of the Gin is known as
a Ginny and this is where we get the
word Genie like rub the lamp Genie yep
oh no
princess
strongest and regular men definitely
he's faced the Galloping hoods a hundred
bad guys with swords who sent the dunes
today was by Prince Ali
oh you didn't see that coming I did I
was just hoping to avoid it
the Gin are typically invisible but when
they want to be seen they can take any
shape they want they're often seen as
large shadowy figures gender able to
take control of a human's body but they
can only do this if the victim is in a
weakened State feelings of unhappiness
and depression can make someone
vulnerable to a gin Jin have free will
and could be either good or evil the
good ones will support assist or protect
humans but the evil ones they can kill
you
[Music]
at a job site there were more than a few
of them could never looked at them
straight on or they were Danish the dogs
react to them every time they appeared
everyone at the job site saw them the
site was up in the northern California
Foothills near Copperopolis this area
was active Native American territory
also was very active during the gold
rush I would be sitting in a chair in
the guard shack looking down the long
driveway when something would catch my
eye in my peripheral view if I turn
forward to a bit of a fetish and I
focused my view down the road I can see
the outline of a person mostly like a
shadow as if the Apparition absorbed
light rather than reflect a part of our
Pass Downs involved at sharing what the
shadow people did during that shift too
many corroborated witness accounts to
write it off
foreign
[Music]
Americans are familiar with the Vietnam
War the proxy war between Cold War
superpowers that lasted from 1955 to
1975. but what about the laosian Civil
War which happened at the same time it
was fought between the kingdom of Laos
supported by the United States and its
allies against Lao Communists it's also
known as the secret war in American
intelligence circles because CIA
recruited thousands of fighters from the
local Hmong population to hold back the
Communists well the secret war did not
go well for the CIA the Hmong people
became refugees and thousands of them
fled to the United States when the Hmong
arrived in America suddenly young
healthy men were dying in their sleep
over a hundred men died this way and
doctors had no idea what caused it but
the Hmong did know it caused it they
believe in an evil night spirit that
sits on your chest until you suffocate
they call it a pressure demon but as
long as you're faithful to your rituals
and keep your ceremonial objects near
your bed you're safe the mom believes
that they were being punished by Shadow
entities for leaving their Homeland to
this day there's no medical explanation
as to why all these young men died when
this story appeared in the LA Times Wes
Craven was inspired to write a nightmare
in Elm Street Freddy Krueger is actually
based on a shadow person and as frequent
as Shadow People encounters were
throughout history it seemed to be a
fringe phenomenon something that
happened in Far Away lands and ancient
civilizations nobody knew how common
Shadow people's sightings were but all
of that would change in 2001 when shadow
people would go mainstream
when I was on active duty in the Marine
Corps stationed at Camp Pendleton
California I had to encountered with the
shadow person late at night on a weekend
I was alone in the barracks Stone Cold
Sober my roommate was on the other side
of the base as I go to bed I turn over
and slightly open my eyes at this point
I see a shadowy figure come out from my
roommate's closet and walked to his bed
I could see arms and legs moving I see
it literally crawl into his bed and
clear as day I see the thing turn over
like it was looking at me in a panic I
back into the wall never blinking and
staring at what I just saw I grabbed my
phone and turned the flashlight on only
to see the bed ending a few weeks later
I finally tell my roommate what I saw
and he was speechless and said he saw
something similar a few days before I
told him it's really difficult
somebody in there
find one find something
somebody's in there they come out
[Music]
my husband and I are paranormal
investigators we lived in Oklahoma we
decided to check out the Joplin's book
light I just turned the car off while my
husband said he could hear a
conversation coming from the field next
to us we didn't think anyone would be
out in the dark in the cold rain just
having a conversation as it looked past
my husband toward the field I saw from
the corner of my eye the light shining
into the car was being blocked starting
from the left to the right I quickly
turned my head and watched this one two
three four Shadows ran behind the car
and completely blocked the light from
the yard light although he had driven
about a hundred miles to investigate the
spoke light I put the car in gear and
knocked it out of there after parking
for less than three minutes my belief
anyway is that shadow people don't
really have anyone's best interest at
heart and I prefer not to spend time in
the company
[Music]
thank you
for you
[Music]
foreign
in April 2001 Art Bell took a random
call on Coast to Coast AM the caller
told Art a story about Shadow People
nobody had ever heard of shadow people
before at least not by this name but art
found the story interesting and asked if
anyone else in the audience had a
similar encounter well 4 500 stories
came in and last week I asked viewers of
the y-files to send their Shadow People
stories we got almost 300 submissions in
one day not bill got way more than you
well of course he did he's Art Bell
you're jealous I'm not jealous it's not
a competition well yeah that's with
someone who loses a competition says I'm
not competing with Art Bell oh that's
abundantly clear
shadow people will fall into one of a
few types the first is just a black mist
without any form it may look like a
cloud of slowly moving smoke you know
this is a shadow person because you can
feel a presence or a negative energy in
the room next human-shaped Shadows these
Shadow People clearly have a body Head
and Shoulders but you can't make out any
features even though you can't see their
face you still get the sense it's
looking at you like the black mist
Shadows these typically disappear when
you look directly at them and this
encounter is the most common
[Music]
foreign
I was experiencing a lot of turmoil in
my life due to an alcoholic and abusive
father at this point is when the shadow
people started appearing never doing
anything just watching it scared me but
I dare not say anything for fear of
being beaten as the years passed my
paranormal experiences increased to
Beyond Shadow People I started seeing
and interacting with full apparitions
once I was with my best friend as a
teenager and a man walked up to us and
just said everything is going to be okay
even walked past us and vanished my
friend just stood there speechless and
in shock when I asked him if he knew
that man he said yes he's my uncle but
he died two years ago as a young man
while in the military that was stationed
at Subic Bay naval base in the
Philippines there many of the locals
witnessed Shadow People apparitions
around me the Filipinos would get scared
and claimed the Oswald we're following
moving up in severity there is the
Demonic shadow person these are
considered very dangerous they're
similar to human-shaped Shadows but
these have glowing red or yellow eyes
and this creature will speak to you
taunt you and threaten you and your
family sometimes the room will smell
like sulfur and often this entity will
grab you or even try to strangle you a
more specific shadow person is called
the old hag this entity takes the shape
of an old woman with features that you
can see and she looks like what western
cultures would consider a typical witch
the old hag will paralyze you climb on
top of you and sometimes try to choke
you and this is another Shadow being
that you can physically feel
my wife and I are on vacation in the
mountains in the middle of our first
night I woke up to the sound of
whispering coming from a corner of the
room I turned to look and realized I
couldn't move then I heard footsteps on
the carpet like the sound of feet
dragging starting to get scared I
desperately tried to move but I still
couldn't I tried to wake up my wife but
I couldn't speak then I felt something
sit on the side of my bed I still
couldn't move but I felt an ice cold
hand on my face and fingers running
through my hair then I felt hot breath
in my ear and a raspy voice whispered
well that put me in full-blown panic but
I was still paralyzed then I saw it it
was an old woman who looked like a witch
she climbed on top of me and smiled this
evil smile all I could hear was her
heavy breath and the sound of my heart
pumping through my ears while holding me
down she started tearing at my clothes I
don't want to get too graphic but she
was violating as the terror Rose I
fought and fought against her but this
just made her laugh finally I could move
and she was gone I told my wife what
happened we stayed the next two nights
on the couch and didn't even go into the
bedroom I was so shaken by the encounter
that we ended our trip early I don't
believe in ghosts and I'm not sure I
believe in Shadow People but what
happened to me felt real to this day
I've never been more frightened in my
life then there's a shadow person known
as the Hat man he's usually an extremely
large shadow creature who wears a
wide-brimmed hat again Freddy Krueger
was a hat man and sightings of the
Batman have been increasing and many
people believe that the hatman is a
warning a sign of the end of times
my story took place in 2003 when I was
17 years old I had the single most
terrifying experience of my life I was
asleep in my room when I suddenly woke
up paralyzed and sensing an unease in
the room despite being awake I was
unable to move any cord of my body
except for my eyes I knew I was awake
because I can hear the TV that had been
left on in the upstairs living room
directly above me as I scanned the room
I noticed movement to my right in the
corner of the room the figure seemed to
appear from the Shadows standing as tall
as my ceiling menacingly hunched over it
had no noticeable features like eyes or
a mouth the figure was dressed in a tall
top hat and slowly floated towards me
its fingers stretching out and seeming
to grow in length as I reached out for
me I felt a genuine sense of complete
Terror wash over me like I had never
felt before almost like the feeling of
dread was being imposed On Me by this
being
The Entity moved closer and closer and
its hand raised in my direction almost
in slow motion and I felt the visceral
sense of evil emanating from the figure
a feeling that I had never experienced
before and have not felt sense despite
the fear that gripped me I was also
terrified by the intensity of the
movement and the Eerie unnatural
movement of the shadowy figure only when
the fear became overwhelmingly intense
did I finally step out of the paralysis
I am a logical reasonable person and I
did not believe in the Paranormal that
is why after the initial Terror left me
I found my whole experience to be rather
entertaining I mean the top app was just
ridiculous I never once believed that my
experience was real and I thought that I
was simply experiencing a waking dream
it wasn't until several years later when
I was watching a documentary on Netflix
called the nightmare that I started to
feel like maybe it wasn't just a
hallucination I experienced all those
years earlier after several minutes into
this documentary someone was recounting
their paralysis experience and they
showed a sketch of what they had
experienced to my shock and disbelief
this sketch was the exact same hatman
figure that I had seen nearly 10 years
earlier I mean exact same how is this
possible I paused the show completely
Frozen in disbelief as for the first
time I knew that I had experienced
something otherworldly that others were
apparently also experiencing seeing a
shadowy human figure was easy for me to
attribute to some sort of common
psychological human manifestation but
the commonality of that very unique top
hat which held no significance to me was
impossible to explain and shook me to my
core
Batman is a type of Shadow being but he
has some traits that make him unique
obviously the most notable feature of
the hatman Shadow entity is his hat oh
is it it's not his button-down cut
against sweater the type of hat varies
by culture some say it's a fedora like
Freddy Krueger some say it's a top hat
in South America they say he wears a
gaucho hat but regardless of who sees
him the hat is always wide brimmed
sometimes the Hat man has glowing eyes
Witnesses say he wears a cloak or a
trench coat he's always tall sometimes
he stands over 10 feet high one thing
everyone agrees on seeing the hatman is
bad news we were living in a house where
a lady hung herself from the rafters of
the Living World upstairs was condemned
used to be two apartments there was so
much activity up there you would have
thought the apartments were occupied
once the landlord came to fix a leak
from up there I told him about the
activity he said no way anyone is up
there it's locked it's impossible I told
him there's constant walking around
constant it banging like someone is
moving furniture a couple of days later
my wife and I started hearing the sound
of one of those springy things that
stopped the door from hitting the wall
just over and over again brown brown
and it's right behind our door we open
the door and the noise is still
happening but there's no springy thing
nowhere for the noise to be coming from
but it's still happening we looked at
each other baffled after two minutes of
the noise it stops the broom is leaning
behind the bunk bed and it flies out and
falls over the dog is spooked and right
there in the trash can slides about five
feet stopping right before the dog he
freaks and he's ready to get out of the
room later in the night our
three-year-old daughter wants to sleep
with us she's in the middle of my wife
and I and at exactly 3am I'm woken up
and standing over me is the tallest
shadow person I've ever seen our roof is
eight feet and he was hunched over
staring directly at me he had a top hat
on and you can see the white in his eyes
and he grinned and I saw white in his
mouth white teeth so naturally covered
my head and grabbed my baby girl and
wife looked about three to four minutes
later and he was gone scared the bejesus
out of me
the Hat man can create or is attracted
to negative energy bad luck illness even
death follow the Hat man I saw the Hat
Man in 2003 I was lying in bed ready to
go to sleep with my boyfriend beside me
I was laying there and looked up and saw
the Hat man standing behind the door I
had never heard about the Hat Man or
shadow people and I thought I was seeing
things or that it was because I had
taken a sleeping pill that night I said
there's a man behind the door my
boyfriend said shut up and go to sleep
that should tell you how concerned about
it we were I eventually went to sleep
and thought nothing else about it my
boyfriend died in this league later that
year which within a few months of this
happening
sometimes the Hat man brings visions of
a future apocalypse some people who've
seen him said he showed them a dark
future nuclear war worldwide disease and
famine the hatman sometimes gets
attached to entire families where
multiple people can see him and once he
latches on it's almost impossible to get
rid of him some people even see him away
from their homes and in daylight this
happened to me 10 years ago when I was a
teenager I was sitting alone at the
kitchen table eating then a sense of
dread at downright paralysis came over
me and I was compelled to look at the
kitchen door right there I can clearly
see the shadow of a man with a hat in
glowing yellow eyes I could only watch
not being able to move a muscle his face
was practically a shadow but I felt him
smile in a condescending Manner and just
like that he rattled the corner and
disappeared I'm 100 sure of what I saw
my taste could not be discounted as
sleep paralysis because I was wide awake
it was broad daylight around 2 or 3 P.M
so who is the Hat Man what are Shadow
People some say ghosts some say they're
from another time or another dimension
others say they're from another planet
[Music]
there is no consensus among paranormal
researchers as to what shadow people are
but the theories are interesting the
obvious theory is that shadow people are
ghosts and when they appear it's a kind
of Haunting but ghosts typically reveal
themselves as light or energy not Shadow
and ghosts usually have defined features
and clothing so I don't think that's
right another theory is that the Shadows
are astral projections of people who are
having out-of-body experiences I
disagree with this one too people who
report seeing astral bodies or astral
projections describe them more like
ghosts than Shadows astral projections
usually have features and are usually
light not dark a very interesting theory
is that shadow people are
interdimensional Travelers maybe the
Shadows are actually people from other
dimensions or realities and are here to
observe maybe the shadow person you see
is actually you From Another Dimension
or another timeline a common theory is
that shadow people are demons Christians
who see the hatman have no doubt that he
is a demon women or the Devil Himself
and there's everybody's favorite theory
that shadow people are aliens there are
many Shadow People encounters where the
entity has large eyes and a small mouth
some people who've seen this type of
Shadow beings say once they focus it
becomes less like a shadow and more like
a creature that's actually there also
reports of shadow people sightings are
extremely common among alien abductees
maybe the aliens are checking up on
their experiment or maybe abductions
begin with the alien emerging from the
Shadows to take them away alien
abductees sometimes report shadow people
as being blue shadows and not very tall
and blue Shadows are seen outside just
as often as they're seen inside some
people believe the aliens are using a
cloaking device or other technology that
gives them a shadowy appearance this
technology also helps them walk through
walls or Disappear Completely encounters
with shadow people feel so real that
those who see them question their own
sanity this is why many if not most
Shadow being encounters go unreported
the big question is is there a logical
rational scientific explanation for
shadow people well I've got good news
and I've got bad news
we usually think of being asleep and
being awake as too distinct and clearly
defined States and usually they are but
inside your brain that line can be a bit
blurry when you're dreaming most of your
brain thinks you're awake if you're
dreaming that you're running playing a
sport or any physical activity your
brain thinks this is really happening
and your muscles want to engage with
whatever you're dreaming about obviously
trying to slay a dragon Full Of Orcs
while you're tucked in next to the wife
would be a problem go ahead and tell him
you're speaking for personal experience
I don't want to talk about it you know
wearing all that armor to bed isn't
helping your sex life I said leave it
alone and it's beyond me how anyone can
sleep in a wooden Cod piece okay that's
enough so while you dream your brain
switches off your muscles this is called
muscle atonia involuntary muscles still
work breathing heartbeat digestion
peristalsis but voluntary motor
functions are shut down this shutdown
occurs during hypnagogia the transition
from wakefulness to sleep during
hypnopia the transition to being awake
your muscles are turned back on you're
asleep during this process so you don't
notice it but sometimes the brain's
wires get crossed and you're conscious
while your muscles are shutting down
have you ever been drifting off to sleep
then suddenly you jerk or kick this
happens when your brain is out of sync
with your sleep cycle you slipped into a
dream before your brain had a chance to
completely shut down your muscles you'll
notice it's happening more often when
you're over tired but sometimes your
brain gets so out of sync that you can
suffer from sleep paralysis this is when
you are fully conscious while your
muscles are Switched Off you're
completely awake but you can't move you
can't turn your head you can't speak all
you can do is move your eyes and
sometimes you can't even do that sleep
paralysis usually just lasts for a few
seconds but sometimes it can go on for a
few minutes and this could be terrifying
during sleep paralysis sometimes you see
and hear things that aren't there these
are a hypnagogic hallucinations and
remember even though you're awake you're
still close enough to the dream state
that your brain stem can activate the
dream mechanism and conjure all kinds of
things so the hallucinations can feel
very real not only can you have Visual
and auditory hallucinations you can
experience some aesthetic hallucinations
this is when your body can feel
something that isn't there the cherry on
top of this horrible experience is the
negativity that occurs there aren't a
lot of happy stories about sleep
paralysis this is because when you're
sleeping your brain has a deficit of the
neurotransmitter serotonin and dopamine
this causes low mood depression and fear
the reason Shadow People encounters
sound so similar is that humans are all
built pretty much the same way it would
be logical for us to hallucinate the
same things but those who believe in
shadow people think there's more going
on than just sleep paralysis the
encounters described are too similar
regardless of Age religion or culture
people see the same Shadow beings
Believers say shadow entities appear
while we're sleeping because that's when
we're most vulnerable so let's all hope
that sleep paralysis creates Shadow
People it because I could think of
nothing more frightening than it being
the other way around
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the Y files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
subscribe like share comment that stuff
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover on this channel today's
topic was recommended by you so if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips special thanks to our patreon
members I can't thank you enough for
making this channel possible if you'd
like to support the channel consider
becoming a member on patreon or grabbing
something from the Wi-Fi store uh yeah I
think we need to redo my contract oh
yeah why is that well what percentage of
merch sold has my face on it
um about 90 my agent would like a word
fine have your people call my people
that's gonna do it until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
watch out for the shadow people
[Music]